we have always had this underlying
threat despite the fact that we've had
the agreement in place now for 25 years
it's understandable when one of the
parties which is in government in
Northern Ireland glorifies terrorism on
a daily basis uh named play parks after
Mass murderers sings of the IRA songs at
many of their functions and they'd have
encouraged many young people to get
involved in this and that makes it easy
for those who wish to continue the
terror campaign to get recruits to
justify what they're doing because they
say they're doing simply what the others
did in the past and that creates a
situation that the security forces have
to deal with Sinn Fein would say of
course that none of those allegations
are appropriate but they're not here to
say that well the lack of government in
Northern Ireland is that not fueling
instability well you know I think one
has to remember that these periodic
terrorist attacks occurred when the
assembly was working functioning fully
so I don't think you can attribute it to
the fact that we've had the
um concerns the security concerns risen
haven't they we have but we've had
severe threats in the past we've also
had killings attempted murders of
policemen while the assembly was sitting
terrorists take opportunities
I think the big opportunity of course is
it will be a lot of international
attention on Northern Ireland during the
uh the anniversary of the the Belfast
agreement and I have no doubt that they
see that as an opportunity to raise the
profile of their Terror and to get
publicity for it so I think that I would
put it down to the fact that first of
all they get an easy supply of recruits
when terrorism was glorified by sin Fein
and secondly they get an opportunity for
international attention at times such as
we're approaching now with the
anniversary of the agreement we've seen
terrorism on both sides of all the lack
of government though you must
acknowledge that the instability at
Stormont can cause problems well you
know as I say that whether the assembly
is up and running or whether it's not up
and running terrorists will always take
no but it doesn't help that there's no
there's there's so there's so much
instability at storm well I mean all I
can say is that the the instability at
storm is caused by the fact that the you
guys won't go back no caused by the fact
that the government in Westminster has
decided to allow the EU to impose
foreign law on a part of the United
Kingdom that's caused the instability we
we thought we were sick
recent polls suggesting that more people
in Northern Ireland support the deal
um than don't support the deal
are you not out of touch with your it
doesn't make it a good deal and it does
and it doesn't change the fact that
you're out of Step that doesn't change
the facts that the government so all of
those people in that poll are wrong no
and you're right no what I'm saying is
it doesn't change the fact that the
government of the United Kingdom which
claims to be a unionist government has
decided to throw part of the United
Kingdom into the arms of a foreign
law-making body and that causes
instability there's no doubt about it
because the unions don't agree well the
the people of Northern Ireland voted to
remain within the United Kingdom that's
the widespread concept well I I doubt
very much of the the polls which you're
talking about if once people understand
the full extent of what is in this
portrayal and don't forget it's
unraveling every day only yesterday the
EU were telling us that we now have to
have fixed border posts at four ports in
Northern Ireland manned by EU officials
approved under EU laws and until they we
do that they will not allow free trade
between GB and Northern Ireland now that
is hardly a recipe for stability where
the government throws part of the United
Kingdom to the worlds and that's what
it's basically it has done and you know
I know that there's been a lot of spin
on the agreement and of course that will
influence people's decisions on it but I
think that once they you dig behind it
uh you'll find that the majority of
people and certainly the majority within
the news Community do not support it and
this is the thing
this is about the thing well this is the
thing with Belfast agreement the Belfast
agreement makes it quite clear that the
status of Northern Ireland can only be
changed with the consent of the people
of Northern Ireland no change can be
made without their consent the Union's
population clearly do not support the um
the northern protocol or the framework
and we will go back into Stormwind when
it is clear we do not have to implement
the laws which are designed to destroy
our position within the United Kingdom
because even the government has admitted
that the application of EU law in
Northern Ireland creates Divergence
between Northern Ireland and the country
to which we belong to and no unionist is
going to collab when are you going to go
back to Power sharing and we'll go back
to Power sharing when we have a
situation where we're treated as fully
as part of the United Kingdom where
we're not required to implement
the laws of the EU which diverges and
and take us away from the undriver wage
between ourselves and the country which
we belong no self-respecting unions
should be expected to collaborate on
their own destruction
um that's not going to happen anytime
soon is it well that's up to the
government there are alternatives I vote
in Parliament last week it's not going
to happen anytime well there are the
government has got a choice of course it
can decide to continue down this route
of disintegrating the the United Kingdom
of driving a wedge between one part of
the country which it governs and another
part of the country or it can't decide
to look for Solutions which are workable
there are solutions which are workable
in fact the government itself put
forward ideas in its own protocol Bill
about dual regulation it put forward
arguments in its own command paper about
Mutual enforcement of a of rules and
it's in the EU and in the UK both of
which they said would work and which
would ensure the security of the EU
single Market while ensuring the
Integrity of the United Kingdom it
hasn't pursued those and if we have to
use the leverage of not collaborating in
our own instruction then we will
continue so you think this could last
for months years more well I I don't I
can't anticipate uh when the government
well you can because the government's
not going to move on it well well they
say they wouldn't move again don't
forget a year and a half ago indeed up
until about six months ago they said
they wouldn't move on the protocol and
they did
um so you know
Sammy and we don't know how long this
prime minister's Gonna Last either but
you know uh I think that the government
will come to the realization that it has
to make a choice between either
defending the United Kingdom or uh
giving a question what would you say to
the people of Northern Ireland who are
really struggling some of them as they
see because of the instability at
Stormont the infrastructure
um of Northern Ireland is disintegrating
well I would say to them that if you
look at the problems that you're now
facing with willingness in the Health
Service yeah a black hole in the budget
the difficulties which we have with uh
financing schools the cost of living
crisis all of those they didn't occur
and they didn't even start in fact they
all originated and we're all exacerbated
when the assembly was running and when
we had a finance minister who wouldn't
put you don't need anything we wouldn't
put through now what I'm saying is let's
not pretend that the assembly is a
Panacea for all of those ills indeed
some would argue and and they don't
think there's a lot of evidence to show
that many of those ills have been caused
by the seasons bad decisions were made
by the assembly so the the the to say
that get the assembly up and running and
suddenly all of these things will
disappear it's just false these things
occurred while the assembly was running
and the important thing for me looking
into the future is can I maintain the
possession of Northern Ireland within
the United Kingdom the fifth biggest
nation in the world and a nation which
we should want to belong to because it's
their long-term advantage